so yesterday I told you that I had
received an email from a viewer with a
link to a video that makes it look as
though in 2012 on stage with MIT Romney
and his wife Ann Romney Donald Trump
might have grabbed the rear end of an
Romney we have the video where we played
we played this video yesterday and we'll
show it to you again today and it's a
moment where Mitt Romney is speaking and
you see Donald Trump sort of shift in a
weird way and Ann Romney seems to almost
like be startled into moving slightly
forward or shifting her buttocks and
Donald Trump when that happens has a
really strange look on his face and
again I presented this not because I
necessarily thought anything in
particular was going on but because a
viewer had pointed it out to me and it
was weird and I mostly expected that
this would disappear and that would kind
of be the end of it well a user on our
YouTube channel went back and found more
video of this same event and pointed out
that Ann Romney as soon as the speech is
over very awkwardly sort of walks away
from Trump and doesn't shake his hand or
anything we got a message there was a
comment left on our YouTube channel
about this and it says David you could
be onto something found the original on
YouTube she even seems to frown towards
the end notice how she quickly leaves
the stage she didn't shake Trump's hand
it seems odd so I went and looked at
that video and it is exactly as this
YouTube viewer describes watch and
Romney as the speech ends leaning away
from Trump and getting out of there just
immediately without shaking Donald
Trump's hand kind of stepping away and
pointing to someone maybe she had to go
and speak to somebody in the crowd
whatever but again individually none of
these are definitive evidence that
Donald Trump did anything the dynamic is
very very strange here though and Ann
Romney stepping away and opting not to
shake hands with Donald Trump after
reacting strangely at a moment where
Trump does seem to reach for something
with his right hand and then have this
weird doofy look on his face
I don't know I'm presenting to you what
I'm seeing this is all coming from the
audience I don't know whether we will
ever learn any more about this but it is
certainly now two pieces of sort of
unusual video from this exact same
incident yeah I wonder how hard it would
be to reach out to an Romney on this one
maybe I'm sure she made the decision
that if this did happen not to say he
didn't want to go public with it
certainly in 2012 when Mitt Romney was
running yeah or even in the 2016 race
when Donald Trump had multiple sexual
misconduct allegations made against him
and it would have been an opportune time
for her to say hey you know what when I
was onstage in 2012 he did so yeah she
could certainly put this to bed with
just one sentence but in the meantime
more and more of our audience thinking
hey David that there is something weird
going on there the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad